لقد مر ما يقرب من ثلاثة عقود منذ أن
أجرت روسيا والصين والولايات المتحدة تجربة نووية، ولكن المخاوف
تتزايد من أن تلك التجارب قد تُستأنف ليس
فقط بسبب المخزونات النووية القديمة
وإنهاء عدد من
المعاهدات النووية، ولكن صور الأقمار الصناعية الجديدة التي
حصلت عليها شبكة سي إن إن تكشف  إنشاءات جديدة
وأنفاق جديدة في مواقع التجارب النووية
في جميع البلدان الثلاثة،
انضم إلينا الآن إيان واتسون من شبكة CNN على الهواء مباشرة من هونج كونج مع
تفاصيل عما يمكن أن يعنيه كل هذا
إيفان جون ليس سرًا أن
هناك توترات سياسية متزايدة
بين الولايات المتحدة وروسيا والصين
وأن الجيوش الثلاثة تجري هذه
التدريبات نوعًا ما
لإظهار قوتها لبعضها
البعض أه منافسة مباشرة ومن
المنطقي أن ذلك سوف
ينزف في النهاية إلى أه شيء
لم يفكر فيه الناس
كثيرًا منذ نهاية  الحرب الباردة،
وهذه هي الترسانات النووية
لهذه الدول الثلاث، وقد ألقت شبكة سي إن إن
نظرة حصرية على
الاستثمار الاجتماعي الكبير الذي تقوم به الحكومات الثلاث
في منشآتها للتجارب النووية،
وأقوى ثلاثة
جيوش في العالم، والولايات المتحدة، وروسيا
والصين، التي توسعت جميعها.
مواقع التجارب النووية الخاصة بهم في السنوات الأخيرة،
الأدلة التي كشفت عنها
صور الأقمار الصناعية التجارية التي حصلت عليها
CNN حصريًا، هذه هي مواقع
التجارب النووية الروسية والصينية والأمريكية،
نوفا، أرخبيل
روسي في المحيط المتجمد الشمالي،
بحيرة مالحة جافة في
منطقة شينجانج الصينية ونيفادا  تُظهر الصور من
موقع الأمن القومي في صحراء شمال غرب
لاس فيغاس من كل موقع
أنفاقًا وطرقًا جديدة ومرافق تخزين تم
بناؤها خلال السنوات الخمس الماضية، وقام
خبير منع الانتشار النووي جيفري
لويس أولاً بجمع هذه
الصور وتحليلها كعامل كبير لكل من
الولايات المتحدة وروسيا والولايات المتحدة.  الصين
رغبة في التأكد من أن
الأسلحة النووية التي صمموها واختبروها في
الثمانينات والتسعينات أه لا تزال صالحة لجميع
الدول الثلاث روسيا والصين والولايات
المتحدة استثمروا قدرا كبيرا
من الوقت والجهد والمال ليس فقط في
تحديث ترساناتهم النووية أه
ولكن أيضًا في إعداد أنواع
الأنشطة التي قد تكون مطلوبة
للاختبار بينما لا يوجد دليل على
وجود اختبار وشيك. شهد موقع نوفايا الروسي
موجة من البناء الجديد على مدى
العامين الماضيين في
الذكرى السنوية الأولى لغزوه الكامل
لأوكرانيا.  أعلن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عن
استعداد روسيا لإجراء
تجارب نووية. وبعض الشخصيات في واشنطن نعرف
ذلك كحقيقة، وهم يفكرون بالفعل
في إمكانية إجراء تجربة طبيعية
على أسلحتهم النووية
إذا أجرت الولايات المتحدة اختبارات،
فسنفعل ذلك
أيضًا، ونرحب بكم في التحالف العالمي الموجود هذا.
يكشف الفاصل الزمني عن 5 سنوات من التوسع فوق سطح الأرض
لمجمع UA، وهو
منشأة تحت الأرض في موقع الاختبار
في نيفادا، وأكد متحدث باسم
إدارة الأمن النووي الوطنية الأمريكية
لـ CNN أن
إعادة رسملة البنية التحتية
والقدرات العلمية في
مجمع UA تضيف الولايات المتحدة  لم تقم الدول
بإجراء تجربة تفجير نووي منذ عام
1992 وليس لديها خطط للقيام بذلك منذ
نهاية الاختبارات فوق الأرض.
استخدمت الحكومات أنفاقًا عميقة لإجراء
تجاربها النووية. تكشف صور الأقمار الصناعية عن
نفق خامس جديد تم حفره في
موقع اختبار لوب نورد الصيني جنبًا إلى جنب مع
كومة متزايدة من الحطام المستخرج
تتهم واشنطن الصين بتوسيع
ترسانتها النووية بشكل كبير ونتوقعها حتى عام
2035 عندما نتوقع أنهم سيرغبون في
امتلاك حوالي 1500 سلاح نووي في
بيان لشبكة CNN،
كما نفت وزارة الخارجية الصينية خططًا لاختبار
الاقتباس  هذا النوع من التقارير لا
يتحدث إلا بناءً على أدلة إشاعات ويضخم
التهديد النووي الصيني دون
سبب. إن
إطلاق شبح تجربة نووية جديدة
من شأنه أن يحطم ضبط النفس الذي أبدته
الولايات المتحدة والصين وروسيا منذ التسعينيات.
فكر إذا كنت مزارعًا في أوهايو أو
صاحب متجر في شنغهاي، التهديد
بإجراء التجارب النووية ليس هو الاختبار
بحد ذاته، بل هو حقيقة أنك
توافق بشكل أساسي على دفع مبالغ ضخمة من
المال في سباق تسلح لا يمكن لأحد أن
يفوز به ولكن يمكن أن
نخسر جميعًا الآن بقدر ما نعرف لا أحد  من بين
هذه الدول الثلاث أجرت
تجربة أسلحة نووية واسعة النطاق منذ
التسعينيات، وكان آخرها الصين في عام
1996 باختبار تحت الأرض أه، كانت الولايات المتحدة
تجريه منذ سنوات اختبارات
تسميها اختبارات دون الحرجة
وتهدف إلى ضمان الموثوقية  من
أسلحتها النووية الموجودة والتي
مضى على بعضها 30 عامًا أو
أكثر مما قد يحتفظ به كثير من الناس بالسيارة،
لذا فأنت بحاجة إلى تحديث هذه الأنواع
من الأسلحة فمن الممكن أن بعض
هذه الحكومات أه تقوم بتحديث
مرافق الاختبار الخاصة بها أه في  الحدث
الذي قد تقوم فيه حكومة أخرى بإجراء
اختبار أولاً ولكن ذلك يبدأ بإدخالك
إلى سياسة حافة الهاوية النووية أه وجنون
العظمة المحتمل الذي
لم نشهد مثله حقًا بين
أكبر القوى العسكرية في العالم منذ
أيام الحرب الباردة